cet adolescent a du mal à en croire ses
yeux dans la nuit son appartement a été
soufflé par une frappe russe
à l'intérieur à la ne peut que constater
les dégâts elle a eu très peur pour sa
mère
maman dormait sur le canapé elle a été
blessée et ils l'ont emmené en ambulance
à l'hôpital de synel nicovo
surtout le Pango du bâtiment les balcons
sont des figurés et de la poussière s'en
échappe encore
si on était réveillés en pleine nuit par
une
expo les agresseurs
russes de kilomètres de là la ville de
Nipro ou Moscou a pris pour cible les
bâtiments d'une unité de secours le
cratère est immense les véhicules
désormais
inutilisables des frappes russes de plus
en plus fréquentes depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines en Ukraine
ce lundi a également été marqué par une
annonce d'avieni Prigogine le chef du
groupe Wagner mais ces menaces à
exécution il prévoit d'achever le
transfert de ses positions à barmut à
l'armée russe d'ici le premier juin une
ville que le Kremlin dit contrôler
depuis samedi version contredite par les
Ukrainiens qui assurent de leur côté sur
place la bataille est toujours en cours
un